et notre premier invité politique de
l'année c'est donc vous marc fesneau
bonjour bon simon content d'être avec
nous ce matin ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne et on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice des cerveaux dont roger fabry
bonjour auriol bonjour marc fesneau
fabrice du coupé bras les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on va
bien sûr longuement parlé avec vous un
marc fesneau de ce texte sur le pass
vaccinale est d'abord un mot sur le
climat dans lequel ces textes arrive au
sénat contexte un peu tendu on a vu ce
week-end une augmentation du nombre de
manifestants anti passent plus de cent
mille selon le ministère de l'intérieur
et puis il ya quelques heures à saint
pierre et miquelon un député de la
république en marge des fans l'hérault a
été violemment agressé devant son
domicile par des manifestants anti pas
ce qu'est ce que vous avez pensé à la
vue de ces images j'ai trouvé ces images
au fond assez effrayante parce que de
voir un homme seul d'entre eux bien
qu'il est chez lui d'abord et que deux
ils cherchent plutôt le dialogue se fait
rejeter toutes sortes d'objets autre
chose devant son domicile avec une
flafla la véhémence une foule un peu
déchaîné il ya quelque chose d'assez
effrayant de ce que son de ce qu'est
devenu le débat politique où le débat
public c'est un jeu les 10 à part voit
tout et d'ailleurs c'est un degré
supplémentaire dans la violence qui est
faite aux élus
l'occasion de rendre hommage à tous les
élus d'ailleurs de tous horizons
politiques parce qu'il ne suffit pas
d'être dans la majorité pour être
menacée et on est parfois parce qu'on
est dans la majorité mais parfois aussi
parce que dans l'opposition fait le
choix de voter telle ou telle mesure et
ne ça n'est pas acceptable en démocratie
justement c'est ce que j'allais dial ce
n'est pas supportable en démocratie
qu'au fond des élus soit dans toutes les
décisions et tous les actes de la vie
d'un élu qui est une la vie d'un élu
c'est un une vie de réflexion et c'est
une vidéo prise de décisions qu'on soit
un élu national d'ailleurs où qu'on soit
un élu local si à chaque moment à chaque
fois que vous devez prendre une décision
on poser la question de savoir quelles
ont été les conséquences non pas
politique mais les conséquences
physiques de menaces qui vont porter sur
vous
et plus grave encore sur votre famille
et dans les deux cas c'est grave je
pense que vous voyez bien la pression
que vous mettez et au fond vous fait
peser sur les lulus l'idée qu'il ne peut
pas prendre sa décision en toute liberté
moi je pense que c'est une chose
extrêmement grave le devoir de
l'ensemble des responsables publics
c'est de condamner sans aucune objection
sans aucune ouimet est où ici sans
aucune
objection il faut condamner ces actes là
parce que ça au bout au bout c'est le
totalitarisme au bout quand vous mettez
des élus nationaux ou locaux à la
pression physique ça veut dire que c'est
la loi du plus fort qui s'impose est la
loi du plus fort qui s'impose c'est le
totalitarisme et ça ça n'est pas
acceptable en démocratie je vois
beaucoup d'élus encore la semaine
derière d'ailleurs à l'assemblée
nationale qui se sentent en permanence
qui ont alors peut-être à tort
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas c'est
quelque chose épié menace est regardée
avec le sentiment que ici sur un bord de
route là au pied de leur domicile ici à
la sortie des hémicycles ils peuvent
être menacés par un individu est donc à
toutes fins en permanence il faut qu'on
soit les uns et les autres solidairement
pas entre nommé solidaire de la
démocratie la démocratie
elle exige du débat de la confrontation
mais elle exige aussi la non violence
c'est c'est avec la violence ce n'est
plus la démocratie qui s'impose c'est
autre chose et moi je je je serai le
premier vous savez que depuis très
longtemps je je mets en garde les
responsables publics y jettent à la
vindicte populaire en disant allez chez
eux allaient à leur domicile aller
manifester devant l'assemblée nationale
parce qu'en france dans ça c'est pas les
élus seulement qu on met lass c'est là
les règles de vie démocratique qui sont
les nôtres et donc je pense qu'on a tous
une responsabilité
voyez des mois avec lequel je le fais
on a tous une responsabilité c'est de
faire vivre le débat démocratique en a
le droit de ne pas être d'accord avec le
pass veille sanitaire ou le pass
vaccinale mais on n'a pas le droit de
menacer quelqu'un à raison de ses
opinions marc fesneau vous avez le
sentiment qu'on a on a franchi une
nouvelle nouveau palier en terme de
violence en termes de radicalité est ce
que j'ai vu hier les images que j'ai
vues hier venant de saint pierre et
miquelon et saint-pierre-et-miquelon ses
6000 habitants 1 c'est une petite
commune française achats échelle que des
gens viennent se permettre de faire ça
je trouve qu'on a franchi un échelon il
ya tout ce qu'on ne voit pas c'est à
dire tous les élus qui parfois au gré
dans leur permanence avec leurs
collaborateurs auxquels je pense aussi
qu'ils aussi se sentent menacés sont en
permanence sous la contrainte et donc là
on a franchi en tout cas visiblement
puisque les images parlent d'elles mêmes
1° qui est à degré insupportable je sais
que l'arrêt procédure ben le masi
donateurs et les éléments de la justice
seront en cours qui verront se met en
route et j'espère qu'on retrouvera les
auteurs de ces faits qui sont
faits le garde des sceaux et le ministre
de l'intérieur eric dupond moretti et
gérald darmanin ont indiqué à plusieurs
reprises auprès d'ailleurs du président
de l'assemblée nationale en particulier
mais nous en parlions la semaine
dernière avec le président larcher je
crois qu'on partage les deux assemblées
partage avec au gouvernement cette
exigence et cette préoccupation
ces renforcements auprès des personnes
qui peuvent être menacés de ses toutes
les menaces qui traînent sur internet et
où il faut aller chercher dès qu'on peut
les gens et les auteurs de ces menaces
les propos d'emmanuel
enfin honnêtement rien à voir on vient
pas découvrir les faits de violence on
l'a dit on les a découverts au moment de
la crise du gilet jaune donc ne faisons
pas des corollaires ou dès le présent la
république a dit au fond ce que beaucoup
de français disent eux-mêmes
si vous n'avez pas entendu ces propos là
et voir plus fort à l'endroit de ceux
qui n'étaient pas vaccinés je crois pas
que ce soit ça qu'ils soient liés le
président de la république il ay là il a
rappelé qu'elle était notre quelles
étaient nos stratégies avec ses mots
avec les mots aussi de l'inquiétude
de d'un responsable public du président
de la république au premier chef de 2
mais moi je pense que la responsabilité
première d'un président de la république
protéger les français et l'art et le
risque principal des français c'est le
risque des non vaccinés d'abord pour eux
et ensuite pour l'ensemble de la société
parce que ça fait peser un risque lourd
sur sur le système de santé et donc je
pense que c'est ça le premier élément de
responsabilité c'est de protéger la vie
des gens et il n'est pas allé trop loin
selon vous mais il l'a dit avec ses mots
et moi ça ne
peut-être pas mais peu importe c'est pas
le sujet je pense que le président de la
république et
le président de la république il est
dans son rôle qui est celui de protéger
les français s'ils n'avaient pas dit ce
qu'il avait dit au mois de juillet
première étape qui était le pass
sanitaires on lui avait déjà reproché à
l'époque d'y aller un peu fort je trouve
qu'il dit et il traduit au fond la
pensée de beaucoup de français et quand
on est président de la république c'est
aussi ça le sujet j'étais encore ce week
end en fin de week-end dans mon
département je vous prie de croire que
ce que j'ai entendu c'est plutôt des
gens qui trouvaient effectivement il
fallait que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités le texte sur le pacs
nike arrive donc au sénat aujourd'hui
est ce que ces propos du président de la
république dont on parle beaucoup de
parlementaires n'y a pas que les
français comparent les parlementaires
aussi en parle est-ce que ça complique
l'examen du texte on entend des
parlementaires disent je ne sais plus
très bien du coup
oui il faut pas ce faux pas moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour l'ensemble des
parlementaires ou le savez c'est
consubstantiel à attendait c'est
consubstantiel à non la vérité c'est non
ceux qui veulent voter pour votre on
pourrait que ceux qui veulent voter
contre ne se cache pas derrière des
arguments qui n'en sont pas
moi je respecte les positions de chacun
par nature est il que l assemblée
nationale comme au sénat je pense qu'on
a réussi avec le sénat l'assemblée
nationale a trouvé un calendrier qui
permet de de deux débats dans des
conditions qui sont deux conditions
satisfaisantes et
jean
castex et eu raison de rappeler que
au final la
lecture s'est un peu accéléré à la
centrale pouvait se poser la question de
voir s'il n'y est pas une possibilité
d'accélérer au sénat le sénat avait pris
un certain nombre de dispositions
on est resté sur le schéma initial très
bien enfin il ya aucune difficulté avec
sa fin je moi je suis pas de ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut accélérer les
processus pour les accélérer le pr le
point miss a juste rappelé qu
effectivement manifestement pensait
finir plus tôt jeudi dans la journée on
a fini jeudi matin très tôt et que
peut-être ça permettait mais au fond le
prémice il est très soucieux aussi du
bon travail parlementaire il en a
dialogué avec le président du sénat
comme j'en avais une dialoguer moi même
aujourd'hui en commission demain et
après demain en séance ça permet de
regarder le texte dans des conditions
qui soient satisfaisantes pour les
sénateurs je crois j'ai pas entendu pour
le coutier difficulté de ce point de vue
là ça permettra un débat serein apaisé
et un débat qui a mis au fond
les conditions sont posées pour qu'il
soit je ne suis pas sénateur
je les connais pas mal mais je ne
prétends pas parler en leur nom et donc
on verra dans quelle mesure les débats
permettront au fond est ce que c'est ça
qui vous regardez c'est le fond du texte
de doter le gouvernement de doter la
puissance publique d'un certain nombre
d'outils qui permettront là encore de
travailler sur comment dirais-je sur la
régulation de cette pandémie je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le sénat sur le pas
sanitaires pour le coup contrairement à
l'assemblée nationale pour ce qui est
des élèves le sénat s'était prononcé
favorablement dans sa grande majorité
pourquoi parce qu'il estimait que
c'était donc je fais confiance aux
sénateurs et au sénat et la majorité
sénateurs est ce que je sais ils savent
être au rendez-vous de l'esprit de
responsabilité je n'ai pas de doute là
dessus voyez ce que je veux dire on a
bien vu qu'à l'assemblée nationale
verra je prêt je présage pas je ferais
offense aux sénateurs mais après il y
aura une commission mixte parce que le
sénat va faire des modifications on
verra tout ça mais je sais que le sénat
dans ces cas-là a été à la hauteur de
ses responsabilités j'ai eu le vote
l'assemblée nationale qui était un peu
confondant côté l air un tiers un tiers
un tiers
bah comme une absence de ligne la vérité
c'est quand on n'a pas de ligne voilà ce
que ça produit
ça veut dire que d'ailleurs ils s'y
seraient en situation de majorité il
n'aurait pas fait voter le pass
sanitaires ou le pass vaccinale ce
qu'ils n'ont pas de majorité pour le
faire c'est comme ça un sujet pour des
gens qui veulent gouverner d'être à ce
point diviser sur un sujet qui est un
sujet
éminent d'urgence sanitaire et donc je
trouve que de ce point de vue là il ya
une petite interrogation qui peut naître
dans les esprits de nos concitoyens sur
le fond du texte
fication caduque si la situation
sanitaire s'améliore c'est des questions
sur le contrôle de ce pass vaccinale est
ce que vous êtes prêts à suivre les
recommandations les propositions du
sapin on verra quelles sont les
recommandations à la commission se
réunit aujourd'hui avait à examiner les
amendements il y aura une séance demain
et après demain dc nous regarder ce que
seront les amendements je rappelle que
dans 75% des cas le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale trouve les voies d'un
compromis au travers des commissions
mixtes paritaires donc c'est des choses
qui arrivent c'est pas des exceptions
c'est plutôt la règle
la preuve que non le gouvernement
puisque on est sur ces dispositions là
et qu après la partie à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat de se mettre
d'accord ou non
on n'a jamais été fermé à des
modifications l'a fait d'ailleurs à
l'assemblée nationale je le rappelle sur
la question du pass vaccinale pour les
mineurs pour les moins de 16 ans donc on
n'est pas fermés au débat c'est
l'intérêt du débat parlementaire c'est
pour ça qu'il faut lui donner du temps
en même temps on a quand même quelques
éléments qui nécessite qu'on aille aussi
vite que possible et donc je pense qu'on
peut on verra sur ces questions là et
sur d'autres s'il ya moyen de trouver un
terrain de compromis on verra comment se
passe la commission justement maintien
de temps galliano talent parler du 17
janvier c'est à dire c'est la semaine
prochaine pour la mise en oeuvre du
passant vaccinale
c'est jouable c'est jouable je peux pas
vous en dire plus oui c'est jouable
c'est jouable c'est un d'accord
assemblée sénat c'est jouable
conditions pour que ce soit joie parce
que je n'ai ainsi pas un accord il ya
une nouvelle lecture qui peut se faire
dans la semaine ce qui aura un recours
au conseil constitutionnel tout ça fait
que ça reste jouable et qu'on sera dans
les horizons qui avait été fixée je
rappelle qu'au démarrage on était plutôt
sûr fin janvier début février et qu'on
reste dans les horizons de la mi-janvier
mais très bien chacun poindra je vais
vous dire chacun va prendre ses
responsabiltés je pense que les français
ne regardent
que parfois les exercices qui sont faits
dans les médias sont pas des exercices
de gens qui sont très responsables de ce
que j'ai vu à l'assemblée nationale ne
m'a pas forcément rassuré de ce point de
vue là mais il ya les besoins des gens
avec une regarde des gens qui
s'intéressent au débat parlementaire et
qui ont le sentiment que tandis que nous
les époux mots non en vaines querelles
il a le virus monté un certain nombre de
gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés ne sont
pas protégés ou ne protège pas les
autres et le système de santé dont
chacun prendra les responsabilités qu'il
à prendre nous nous prenons les nôtres
je crois qu'on peut reconnaître et que
les français reconnaissent que nous
ayons à chaque fois pris nos
responsabilités quand souvent et trop
souvent malheureusement d opposition
n'est pas pris leurs responsabilités
quand vous regardez ce qui se passe en
allemagne en italie ou ailleurs souvent
quand même les majorité-opposition
réussi à trouver un terrain d'entente
pourquoi parce que il avait un esprit de
responsabilité et moi j'appelle à la
responsabilité a dit juste moyen il a
mis en place six nations pour les plus
de 50 ans pourquoi ne pas être allé au
bout
et mettre en place
plutôt que de faire c'est pour une
raison simple et très bien rappelé qui a
été pour une raison simple qui a été
très bien rappelé par le président de la
république une fois vous mettez en place
l'obligation vaccinale comment vous la
mettez en oeuvre vous allez chercher les
gens chez eux ou les emprisonner ou les
embastiller jusqu'à ce qu'on ait trouvé
un moment
mais en italie il démarre ont rendez
vous dans quelques semaines par ailleurs
manifestement étant le pays du monde je
crois pas dire de bêtises ou l'inde et
pays du monde où le taux de vaccination
est le plus élevé manifestement notre
stratégie n'est pas si mauvaise donc
c'est vraiment ce qu'on avait entendu le
pass le post vaccinales c'est pour
éviter de mettre des gens en prison non
mais voyez bien mais
vous voyez bien que ceux qui disent
qu'il faut faire l'obligation vaccinale
c'est l'impuissance publique qu'on
prépare c'est une fois qu'on a dit ça
comment on fait
on va chercher les gens devant le
gendarme et on les amène un sillon de
l'axé nation obligatoire en france elles
sont obligatoires mais ça veut pas dire
que le taux de vaccination est à 100% on
est à 92 % la vaccination est
obligatoire pour les enfants les neuf
vaccins dont on avait eu elle est
obligatoire tous les enfants sont pas
vaccinés
donc ça va parce qu'elle est obligatoire
qu'elle est appliquée la question c'est
pas qu'elle soit obligatoire la question
c'est quelles soient le plus largement
répandu et la vaccination obligatoire ne
rend pas tous les enfants vaccinés donc
faux faux faux
faut arrêter de dire ça il faut arrêter
de 2 quand on est un responsable public
c'est ça peut être séduisant la
vaccination obligatoire mais je répète
vous allez chercher les gens entre deux
gendarmes ou les années dans les centres
de vaccination vous donner à des gens
qui gagnent à peine le smic une amende
de 1500 euros mais au fond être sérieux
c'est pas comme ça qu'on gouverne un
pays dont qu'on a on est effectivement
on a fait le choix de pousser
sur le sur l'orientation vaccinale en
faisant peser la charge effectivement
sur ceux qui n'étaient pas vaccinés mais
sinon on est inopérant d'ailleurs le
seul territoire de la république qui a
fait rendu la vaccination obligatoire
c'est la nouvelle calédonie parce qu'ils
ont des prérogatives de santé et le
résultat n'est pas là non plus parce que
c'est comme ça que ça se passe là la
réalité humaine n'est pas celle là en
tout cas dans une démocratie quand on
n'est pas dans un régime démocratique
c'est facile de rendre la vaccination
obligatoire
des opposants à l'atteinte aux libertés
surtout dans une période où le parlement
est plus sensé siéger puisque entre fin
février et fin juin le parlement n'est
pas sensé siéger pour cause donc il peut
toujours sujet c'est la question que
j'allais vous poser est ce qui pourrait
être convoqué serait juridiquement et le
sujet
mais on n'envisage pas mais il peut
siéger c'est plus pas la question la
question n'est pas là est ce que c'est
possible oui est-ce que c'est envisagé
non et sebouh smith mais pourquoi
il faudrait avoir un événement qui
justifierait de le faire est ce que vous
avez ça sous les yeux aujourd'hui la
réponse est non mais en tout cas le
parlement puis les parlementaires
restent parlementaire je parle en tout
cas les sénateurs évidemment ceux qui
n'ont pas de processus électoral mais
les députés restent débuté jusqu'au
dernier jour de leur élection est ce que
j'ai est ce que dans ce plan est
notamment ce vote vous avez intégré être
que les choses pourraient aller mieux
dans les prochaines semaines
oui alors amis on a déjà vu ce débat
d'ailleurs je le rappelle au moment du
de la prolongation de passe à lithaire
et des dispositifs d'état d'urgence au
mois d'octobre ou novembre le texte
juste avant celui ci on nous avait
expliqué qu'il fallait même arrêté le
pass sanitaire parce que on était en
train de sortir de la crise alors j'ose
à vous dire quelque chose cette crise
nous apprend à être modeste et prudent
et donc on est modeste et prudent et
donc j'entends tout ce qu'ils disent
yaka on va être sorti tous les
épidémiologistes de comptoir nous sommes
tous un peu sélectionneur de foot
épidémiologistes désormais mais moi je
considère que c'est des choses sérieuses
et que donc il faut qu'on ait des outils
qui nous permettent de rapidement réagir
et donc c'est dans cette disposition la
con et heureusement qu'on n'avait pas
supprimé les dispositions
état d'urgence ou préparant l'état
d'urgence si l'on serait dans une
situation n'aurait pas pu agir sur un
certain nombre de lieux même si ces
malheureux sur les discothèques par
exemple et du coup la présidentielle se
déroulera sous covin les sénateurs
notamment centristes ils veulent des
dispositions pour encadrer le scrutin
sur le plan sanitaire est ce que ça
manque
actuel
mais ce n'est pas une affaire de textes
principalement le premier ministre
réunira demain si j'ai bonne mémoire
l'ensemble des forces politiques
avec la méthode que vous lui connaissent
et il réunit il prévient il dialogue on
prend des dispositions il réunira avec
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin je sais qu'on trouvera des
voies et moyens pour trouver la manière
de faire campagne a pas de raison qu'on
n'y arrive pas on y est arrivé si
c'était compliqué parce que là on était
dans une phase épidémique nouvelle aux
municipales minutes arrive aux
régionales et autres
gardes
alors sur ces sujets là il ya ce qui est
possible et ce qui est possible dans le
délai donc on va regarder et il faut
aussi qu'ils aient un consensus des
forces politiques me semble-t-il au
moins on s'en suit aussi large que
possible donc on va regarder quelles
sont les propositions je viens pas
préempter un débat qui va commencer
demain sur ces sujets là
mais on va regarder enfin je n'ai moi je
n'ai pas de davie il faut en tout cas
dans cette affaire là qu on est à trois
mois du scrutin que ces dispositions où
les dispositions les ajustements si les
ajustements qu'on pourrait faire soit
acceptée parce qu'ils vont concourir oui
mais dans la situation dans laquelle on
est nous de gouverner on va pas venir
imposer contre l'ensemble des forces
politiques des choses zac feno est ce
que vous craignez une faiblesse de la
participation que vous évoquez les
régionales et les mini ça a été quand
même le principe c'est vrai est ce que
vous craignez pour ces raisons qu'il
faut à la fois qu'on regarde je pense
qu'il ya deux il ya ceux qui peuvent
craindre d'aller dans les bureaux de
vote encore que ce n'est pas les lieux
qu'ils soient les lieux les plus à
risque objectivement pour avoir retenu
moi même mon bureau de vote dans ma
commune de marchenoir donc jouée à peu
près de quoi il est question et la
distanciation et les règles de prêt de
prudence ce s'applique aux fauves assez
facilement dans un bureau de vote même
si ça va compliquer la vie des élus et
jouerait salué le travail qu'ils font
pour essayer de faire les choses dans
les meilleures conditions possibles donc
il ya un premier à risques c'est lui a
pris un risque de démobilisation
générale donc sur les le premier c'est
d'essayer de rassurer de mettre en place
des protocoles qui sont rassurants pour
les gens peut-être d'avoir des mesures
d'assouplissement appuyé sur le deuxième
c'est à nous de faire une campagne qui
intéresse les gens tant qu'il y avait
fait citer d'une vraie campagne ah oui
il ya nécessité d'une vraie campagne est
ce que c'est on voit bien que est ce que
les formats meeting permanent d'heure
objectivement depuis des années on voit
bien que galles est très très grand
meeting écolo reste c'est un peu
amenuisé on va dire ça comme ça la
campagne ne se fait plus pareil
l'émergence des réseaux sociaux des
chaînes d'info continue et en
particulier pour une présidentielle créé
des conditions qui sont particulières
donc pas tout à fait de toute façon les
vins campagne qu'à 20 ou 30 ans voilà
donc on va regarder on va ajuster les
partis politiques aux mêmes ajustements
d'ailleurs plusieurs dida disent ne pas
avoir leur parrainage dont jean luc
mélenchon dont eric zemmour ou katniss
de la participation citoyenne est ce
qu'il faut changer les règles de
parrainage et remplacer des parrainages
d'élus par des parrainages de citoyens
écoutez on va pas changer les règles a
promis un scrutin bon alors après
quelques questions se posent mais au
bout du bout à date et j'espère que ça
restera ainsi citez moi un candidat peu
significatif qui n'est pas pu être
candidat ces vingt dernières années
je sais pas si à du bluff ou à la fin
globalement les candidats qui pesait
quelque chose dans le débat public ils
ont été présents et parfois à des
candidats qui ne faisait pas grand chose
donc pour vous la règle actuelle
fonctionne il ne faut pas y toucher mais
moi je les jeux comme des questions marc
fesneau est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur la
question de l'anonymat en tout cas
humains non publicité alors c'est là
c'est la grisaille oui elle moi j'ai
connu la règle de l'art et qui
s'applique aujourd'hui c'était la règle
de 2002 c'est à dire qu'on vendait en
fou au fur et à mesure public les
parrainages
puis on avait complètement anonymisées
puis on avait bon bref
est ce que c'est un frein jeu je sais
pas les maires il exerce d'abord je
rappelle une chose parce que je vois
beaucoup de collègues maires qui disent
je parle comme un ancien élu ou un élu
que je suis pardon de le dire comme ça
qu'ils disent je vais consulter mon
conseil municipal au fond c'est pas une
nécessité puisque c'est le parrainage
n'est pas une caution du candidat le
parrainage et je veux que cette personne
participe du débat démocratique il ya
des gens qui ont parrainé par x et les
gens qui n'étaient pas dans le champ est
dans le registre ça se comprend et ça
s'explique
donc il ya plutôt ça a expliqué dans
l'opinion y compris dans l'opinion
municipal c'est à dire que quand un
maire pareil tel ou tel candidat c'est
pas pour autant qu'ils en aient un
soutien et un premier défenseur mais je
pense que ça ça a disparu dans l'état
d'esprit en gros vous parrainez vous
soutenez donc il ya quelque chose à kaka
c'est de cet ordre là est-ce que
l'anonymat mais un temps l'idée que ce
qu'on se cacherait de soutenir tel ou
tel candidat me gêne je vois bien que ça
peut être un frein pour certains mais
l'idée que dans une démocratie ça
revient de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur des mugs des élus qui sont
menacés en menacerait un élu à raison de
son parrainage à tel ou tel candidat
il est quand même dans un drôle de
système c'est quoi cette démocratie de
l'anonymat
est-ce qu'il faut partager quand même on
y sont partagés sur le sujet non non je
je je je
j'assume tout à fait c'est mais
ça facilite sans doute le fait qu'on
donne son parrainage mais ça me gêne
qu'on puisse pas assumer publiquement à
parrainage un candidat oui donc on s'en
partager mais moi je dis juste que les
faits sont têtus je demande à voir ce
qu'elle est le candidat aujourd'hui qui
significativement présents dans les eaux
dans l'opinion a n'a pas pu être
candidat je n'en vois pas donc je pense
que monsieur mélenchon est au fond c'est
heureux et monsieur zemmour pareil
seront candidats ils ont leurs
parrainages après je connais d'exercice
de ceux qui font monter un peu les
choses je ne parle pas de ces deux
personnalités là mais en soi et retenez
moi ou ça fait très peur des mots je
peux être candidat
cet exercice qualité de la campagne
donc annoncé son soutien
il est élu guillaume pelletier du même
département vous il reproche notamment à
valérie pécresse de faire le joueur de
l'annuel mâcon campus vont
te dis oh pelletier est un aventurier de
la politique
fidèle politique qui est infidèle
territoriales il a été candidat à
epernay il a été candidat tour il nous a
expliqué ses racines solognote il nous a
dit combien il aimait le mandat de
municipal il est resté deux ans comment
il aimait le mien des régionales il est
pas retourner au combat régional qu'est
ce que je voulais je vous dise la vie
politique est traversé de personnalités
comme ça se peut pas dire qu'il n'a pas
du talent d'ailleurs mais elle
traversait de personnalités qui sont à
leur compte total aventuriers totaux
nous ça discrédite l'ensemble de ses
propos il a fait à peu près toutes les
boutiques il a été éphémère mans
centriste en 2015 au moment des
régionales pour pouvoir travailler avec
nous avec philippe vigier à l'époque on
pas dire que ce soit la force des
convictions qui soit sa caractéristique
première mais à partir de là moi qui
n'ai pas changé de famille politique je
le regarde comme un être un peu étranger
à ma façon de faire de la politique et
avec pas plus d'intérêt que ça
figurez-vous parce que
je il ya des gens à l air qui ont des
convictions ils ont droit les avoirs
après sa valeur donc voilà pour ce
qu'ils
ont fait pas des tournants avec des gens
qui font des zigzags enfin je veux dire
pardon sur la tradition la campagne
c'est ainsi d'ailleurs c'est une bécasse
pour revenir à la question ce sont ceux
du vol de la bécasse pour revenir de
pardon il sera temps défi
laissez moi finir en revanche ça pose
une question aussi ou à l'air c'est
qu'ils ont acceptée dans leurs rangs
monsieur pelletier qian chiasso or un
petite interruption toujours été sur une
ligne très à droite et à force d'avoir
couru derrière monsieur zemmour est
d'avoir la rhétorique de monsieur
zemmour les gens ils préfèrent
l'original à la copie par che est mort
donc il faut que l air j'ai pas de
conseils à leur donner ce sont des
adversaires politiques printemps dans le
débat démocratique
moi je ne je ne cherche pas
l'humiliation des adversaires je pense
qu'on a besoin d'une gauche j'en avais
parlé un petit à l'heure attendez on a
besoin d'une droite mais à force de ne
pas choisir entre la ligne zemmour et la
ligne plutôt des républicains qu'on a
connus version chirac c'est assez
original de voir monsieur pelletier
défendent le rpr qu'il a pilonné quand
il était chez monsieur le pen ce que
c'était monsieur à l'époque et chez
monsieur de gilley donc faux faux faux
quand même toute honte bue un bon peu
importe mais le rpr de jacques chirac ce
n'était pas un repère qui courait
derrière monsieur zemmour voilà et donc
je pense que cette confusion des esprits
chez les l'air ils sont en train de la
payer et le départ de monsieur pelletier
qui est anecdotique pour ce qui est de
la personnalité il est symptomatique
d'un formation politique a pas fait ses
choix merci pour merci d'avoir été notre
invité merci fabrice
[Musique]